how much hardware do you have in your
body
um i have had three broken necks
so um i've got a
fusion at c5 and six a disc replaced at
six and seven a disc replaced at seven
t1 and then my neck fused itself at c2
and three because of
scarring from like injuries um and how
many of those
injuries you just listed are from
jackass uh i broke my neck twice
in the last film we did previous to what
we are just working on now so what's
what bits uh i think it was number three
there was uh
and up in the snow shopping cart he was
sitting there and they were gonna have
him ski across like a
little body of water yeah no but i got
in a shopping cart
and i've been the fastest built on water
skis or something it was on no it was on
regular skis and and eric
rohner all right right pushed me through
uh down the hill and they built this
pond that i was supposed to land in
and the gag was that i'd get wet and
then i'd walk over to get a towel and
they would just
a whole like eight foot hole drop drops
off and then i eat [ __ ] in there and
then i
think some steaks or some [ __ ] well no
and i told jeff i was like yo
i'm pretty good with knowing how like
velocity and like
stuff i've made a career off of this my
whole life has been about
hucking my body and surviving and i said
i'm gonna hit that wall
i'm gonna flip hit that wall and break
my neck and he's like no you'll be fine
and sure enough i did and it whipped
and i knocked out and i get in the water
and i'm
i'm i'm fully concussed and i come too
because it's ice cold water and i get up
and i'm like oh my god and everyone's
looking at me literally like they
thought they killed me
in full speed and regular speed it was
[ __ ] violent as [ __ ]
yeah and and i'm standing there like
looking at them like
like should i be walking right now like
what should i do because i feel like
i'm i'm dying and
they all looked at me like oh god what
that went wrong
what do we do now and then somebody said
the towels are over there and i'm not
[Applause]
even knowing that i had already probably
like
i was a [ __ ] ghost i was just walking
they thought they killed me
they didn't understand it fell in the
hole and i'm laying in there going are
you
kidding me right now
just like that
no because they felt so bad that's
another example where they couldn't show
what actually happened
because it was too much if we had just
like not the 0.5 because even the 0.5
can't show the
like a lot of the gnarly stuff if we had
i mean i don't know that there's that
much
footage that was like couldn't be shown
i mean
it sounds like like uh you're falling
with a broken neck into an eight-foot
hit like it does count why but like
there's
lots of things man we've been doing this
for 21 years
like why would he what comes to mind
yeah well okay take for instance i did
something that you would have seen that
you might not know the backstory of what
you really could have seen
um yellow snow cone where i
i pee into a snow cone i saw that and i
was like man that's low brow even
for us no but not at the beginning and
it was
it was awesome like you can say what you
want
people remember it that's true
absolutely
yeah so so my original idea with that
was that i wanted to make a snoopy snow
cone machine
like pea cone and we couldn't get like
hasbro or
whoever owns that brand to clear off
that so
so i was like okay well what about this
and we just stuffed
you know was snowing in portland in
dave's backyard
and that's when we filmed that and i
peed in a snow cone
and i ate it and it was pretty gnar but
it wasn't like
super gnarly like compared to what yeah
we do now but back then it was like
you don't show that stuff for real on a
movie on tv or was it on that that was
the movie
it was in the first movie like you just
don't show real stuff like that on a
film in a theater theaters at the time
and so i did that dave kicked me the
nuts that felt really not cool
whatever and i dropped to my knees and i
started puking because it was disgusting
and he hit me
kicked me so hard on the dick that my
stomach basically like was exploding
with all the food that i had just eaten
and so i puked all over the place and
then i
stuff i pick up that snow and i stuff it
into the snow cone thing and i
look at the camera dimitri i think and i
go and now this
is the brown snow cone and then i ate my
puke
in the snow and they never showed that
they can't show that it's not because
it's disgusting i don't know i mean
you can't show that like we did that but
there was they ever showed the vomit
when uh dave we had to reshoot that
three times just to get it because of
all the
and that was why they had hazmat suits
and [ __ ] i'm not sure i talked to jeff
the other day about that i don't know
like i can't remember how about on the
first movie when you did the mousetrap
thing and you were like crawling around
in the
with all the mouse traps everywhere yeah
and that was like it was like all right
that's kind of cute but then what was
like the most
amazing thing that anybody had ever seen
was
when was that knoxville through the
mouse trap
and slam yeah like how [ __ ]
incredible was that can you imagine
trying to do that on purpose
you know it'll never happen again yeah
the thing about doing the mousetraps
that was so gnarly or
whatever impressive to me was that when
you set 2000 mouse traps if one goes off
a lot of them go off and then you've got
the that whole problem and we
like were able to set 2 000 mouse traps
for me to roll through so that was
pretty cool
what would you say if they were like
okay we're going to redo that old
mousetrap bit but it's going to be rat
traps with rat traps yeah i
i i'm uh why what's the difference
bigger and harder
yeah they're heavy dude rat traps if a
rat trap gets
clamped around your balls you you're not
having balls dude
so just don't just squish them
completely so when you put your tongue
on a trap it's a mouse trap
yeah you don't do a rat trap oh you
could yeah rat traps are [ __ ] up
what's the point right maybe a little
too much i don't know i get it maybe
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude